problem in Birmingham and other cities
with regards to taking Balloons with
laughing gas it has created many deaths
casualties and serious health problems
in our Muslim communities both brothers
and sisters and it mainly Muslim
yeah any shops that are selling them
what is your advice firstly
alhamdulillah again you know with
regards to this laughing gas
I don't know the effects that it has
upon the individual but if it's
something that clouds the intellectual
is Haram then it's considered to be a
hammer
and if it's something that people can
die from then definitely we know that
from the primary objectives
preservation of life
don't put yourselves in a situation of
Destruction
so no doubt it is something that's
forbidden and the game prevention is
easier than a cure why are you going to
start these type of habits when you
start these habits it's difficult to
stay away from them the best thing
alhamdulillah teaches us to stay away
rather than start and try and stop when
you start something it's harder to stop
rather than alhamdulillah if you're
nurtured upon something and you stay
away from it inshallah you will not
return to it that is why you find many
times drug addicts you know sometimes
they return During certain times and
they delve in drugs and taking drugs
because you know that's something that
they were accustomed to may Allah
protect the Muslims from that
the best thing is what staying away from
it if you've never had a drug in your
life alhamdulillah
it's a blessing when you can say you
know I've never tried a drug in my life
that's enema somebody may look at you as
being strange that's a blessing it's a
blessing a saying I've never smoked a
cigarette in my life that's a blessing
well I've never smoked marijuana in my
life that is a blessing
don't let anyone you know convince you
otherwise that you know you should feel
strange because you never did those
things now that's a blessing that Allah
Israel kept you away from those things
and that is
a virtue
that no muslim Muslims should be
embarrassed of